in this case study the challenge was to
focus on one very important
characteristic of this very flexible
electronic sensor and that in fact is
what we're going to focus on in this
attempt to show the flexibility of this
very very thin film of electronics so I
first put it on something that is
strange it's actually the inside of a
plastic petri dish and I'm thinking that
that's showing the flexibility and I
took another point of view of the same
setup I kind of liked it because I'm
very very focused in and you could see
the bending and folding then I tried
something a little more rigid a piece of
cardboard that was folded in a couple of
areas sort of like that one the
researchers took their own images which
are these in front of you showing that
this sensor is placed on the skin and
that it stretches and I'm not sure about
which images are better these definitely
show the stretch ability and flexibility
of this very thin membrane sensor
whether or not you want to look at this
for a long time is another story but
maybe take a look at the differences and
you make the decision